you actually recorded a pre-tax loss for
the year was that down to competition
from uber or other factors no not at all
it was really about we did two
acquisitions in the year that we've just
reported on integrated those together
we've been investing really heavily in
technology as well so what you'd see
here is the footprint of the business is
increased by a third heavy investment
lining ourselves up for really strong
growth in the community yeah so this
move outside the UK what proportion of
sales are you anticipate coming from
Britain and how much from elsewhere in
future so at the moment 25% of our sales
are outside of the UK over the next
three years we expect that to move to
about 50/50 there's a massive
international market for what we do and
you know the first move on that is
customers in New York in particular are
saying to you as we really like what
you're do in London
please bring at us and eat in New York
and we're expanding there really quickly
and you'll trade under that brand in New
York as well I know you have the Tristar
brand which is slightly different but
the Adelaide brand will be the one that
you trade under everywhere yeah so
there's this two products here one is in
big cities big financial cities in
particular that at scale Addison Lee
product for business customers
definitely a winning proposition and
then tristar's are global high-end
chauffer service and we've just launched
that service in a hundred cities around
the world on web and apps we've
digitized that network now gives you
such confidence that you're gonna be
able to roll out Addison Lee it's a
global brand I mean these are very local
markets on it some cases well you know
it's been a really immature market and
very fragmented and what we've seen in
London London's the most competitive
market for these sorts of services that
when you offer quality at a reasonable
price
invest in your proposition and get the
best possible drivers and cars actually
people come to you and that's the
offering that premium differentiated
service gives us real confidence so it
can grow elsewhere
now obviously Luber has given you a bit
of a tough time in your domestic markets
Transport for London wants to strip them
of their operators license do everything
that's actually going to happen well I
can't comment on that and that's between
Transport for London and uber what I
would say though is that these sorts of
services you really need
to end operating model customer service
support manage your drivers manage your
fleet make sure you're properly looking
after customers because in that way not
only is it what customers want
particularly our business customers but
it really lines up much more closely to
what regulators are looking for up in
London but also in elsewhere around the
world